>>, BYE.
THE PE
I , RIGHT?
PERFECT ANSWER
AND  HSUCCEEDS AT
TU TION AT THE CYLR PLANT.
E IT CE BACK INTO
COAT WD IS REALLY
. CNN'SLEITGEN
WITH MORE.
>>> HI THERE
U THE UKRAINIANS FROM G WHENS
TOOK OVER THL NUCLEAR WER PLANTE
ABSOLUBOUT WHAE DOING THERE.
WHERE WEWO
THINGS THAT REALLY THE ONE HANE
TREATED BADLY BUT IT ALSO SEEMED
ALLOWED THEIR OWN FORCES TO GET
EXPOSE MASSIVE WHAT WE FOUND.
SIMPLY GETTING TO THBYL
EXCLUSION ZONE IS A TREACHEROUS
S AND BRIDGES
DE GO OFF-ROADCROSSING RIVERS
BRIDGES.
FINAEACHED T
CONFINEMENT DOF E POWE
W WOR ACCIDENT ER.PSED
WAR AGAINST UKRAINE AND TOOK
NO NATAL STAFFHE TER TOLDS TO CE
KEPT69
E THE  TIS ACE.
RDD WHENHE RUSSIANS LEFT THEY OC
AND SOLDIERSUKRAINE'S R HEVE
TAKEN THEM TO , AND EY THEY'RE G
WHEN I ARRIVEDE I
SHOCKED, HE T ONLY ONCN REALIZE
IT IS ALYSOCIATED
THICTIMS, WITH BLOOD AND
VIOLENCE.
RE IS A VIVID
EXAMPLOFHAATILITY.WHILPLANT'S T
X WITH CLEAR SAFETYO KEEP HE UKA
IS NATIONAL ANBROUGHT THE RADIA
GUARDSMAN SAYS. ELSIS RI ASK HE
SAYS.
THRADIIOASED HERBECAUSE THEY LIE
EVERYWHERE.
T SHOESI
WILET'S GE SAY OF THE ST
INEDWOLY THEOI
DTAY THE RUSSIANS COMBA
POE.E OPERATORS SAYS THOSOLDIERS
AMOUNTS OF ION.
WE WENT TO THE EDGE OF TFOREST
WHEN WE HOLD THE METER CLOSET
NUCLEAR SAFETY IN EUROPE. A
THE CHERNOBYL NUCLEAR POWER SN'E
AND ALSO THERE'S
SPENT NUCLEAR FUEL I
AND IT'S N CHERNOBYL.SSIAN TROO
ROLARGES
NUCLEAR POWER AN
UTHERNKR AND ARE NOW
OCCUPYING IT.E PFLS ERGY NIMEHE.
>> I THINK IT'S DRAMATICALLY
IMPACT, AND THAT I THE
OF NUCLEAR HEY AR
>> Reporter:S E
N ARMYOUTE ATTACK THE CAL.S
TO DEFEND THIS BORDER THE
MINISTER SAYS.E BORDER B
TOTALITARIANISM ANMOY EHIND OUR.
THE BORDER BET ESSION.
WE ARE READY TO T D  FEAR THEY Y
HA TT AGAI AS
IDENT VLADIMIR PUTINS FORCES TI
D NUCL IN EUT
RISK.U KNOW, DON, I SPOKE TO
UKR ED PERIOOF
NTE ENTIRETHE RUSSIANS TO FORCE
WORLD ANDOBODE WELL FOR
THE FACT THEY ALSO STILL CONTR